pragmatische lösung sie sprechen es an
gleichzeitig nutzen das aber auch
unternehmen wie zum beispiel adidas aus
und jetzt einfach zu sagen wir zahlen
keine miete mehr
wie geht man mit solchen ja doch
wohlhabenden unternehmen um die das
jetzt nutzen sozusagen um zu sagen wir
können unsere miete nicht mehr zahlen
ja ich bin enttäuscht von adidas ich bin
sehr enttäuscht
ein unternehmen das so viel gewinn
gemacht hat
solche tolle produkte herstellt die
natürlich made in germany weit über
deutschlands grenzen hinaus den sport
prägen
solche botschaften abzusetzen gerade mal
24 stunden nachdem wir über hilfspakete
geredet haben und hilfs schirme
aufgespannt haben als erste in der welt
so richtig als erste in europa in
billionenhöhe als politik
parteiübergreifend entschieden haben man
muss ja sehen am montag war kabinett da
haben wir beschlossen am mittwoch
entscheidet der deutsche bundestag
was ich vom abstimmungsverhalten her
gesehen hat parteiübergreifend ein
klares signal der solidarität
am freitag gibt der bundesrat grünes
licht und dann kommt ein unternehmen das
so erfolgreich ist und geht mit einer
botschaft an das zum schaden von
vermietern ist es sind nicht nur die
großen immobilien einrichtungen die
irgendwie adidas am laden vermieten
sondern es sind auch kleine die als
privatpersonen diese flagship stores von
adidas vermieten die bleiben dann auf
den kosten sitzen eine völlig
inakzeptable botschaft sie sagen sind
enttäuscht aber die vermieter fragen
sich was kann die politik tun um ihn
dagegen adidas sozusagen zu helfen was
können sie tun was kann die
bundeskanzlerin
ja ich werde diese ganz neue nachricht
nehmen für die nächste woche ist ja
jetzt akut auf den tisch gekommen dass
das keinen domino-effekt hat für andere
das signal ist nicht solidarisch das
signal ist nicht das unterhaken dass man
von jedem bürger verlangt wir geben die
botschaft an die bürgerinnen und
aber seid vernünftig das sage ich auch
da müssen große konzerne auch vernünftig
sein